hello readers today i want to begin with
a brief aside about physics unless
you're like a quantum particle or
something it's not possible to be in two
places at once
nor is it possible to travel in two
directions at once
right if i'm on a train from chicago to
pittsburgh i can't simultaneously be on
a train from chicago to omaha so my body
can't travel in two directions at once
but
my mind can what what i know
it is possible to think two ideas at the
same time ideas that are equally
important but may not necessarily
support one another
i can be thinking it's hot outside and
i'm late for my train and those two
ideas can have equal weight in my mind
the same thing can happen in texts an
essay where an argument or a book can
have two or more main ideas
it's a train that can go east to
pittsburgh and west to omaha at the same
time
this is a confusing idea when you look
at an essay you think what's the main
idea in this text what is the author
trying to tell me or what position are
they trying to convince me of
so how can there be room for more than
one idea how can we tell that a piece
has two main ideas and not just one idea
with supporting evidence
alright here's an example of two main
ideas
sharks are deadly predators and fierce
hunters
they hunt with sharp teeth incredibly
sensitive noses and the ability to sense
the electrical current of a living body
many people are afraid of sharks because
encounters with them can be fatal that's
paragraph one however sharks need to be
protected because they are important to
ocean ecosystems their roles as high
level predators ensures that they
maintain population levels of smaller
fish which in turn maintains the balance
of ocean plant life if there were no
sharks algae could take over the ocean
now both of these paragraphs are about
sharks so in one sense it's true that
the passage as a whole is about sharks i
just draw a little shack
he's so
scary
look at those very sharp teeth
anyway the topic is sharks but what's
the idea here in each paragraph
paragraph one says sharks are deadly and
here's why and paragraph 2 says it's
because of their deadliness that they
need to be protected because big
predator species balance ecosystems
these are two ideas that are separate
but interrelated sharks are deadly
sharks need protecting on its face those
two ideas almost seem like they
contradict each other or cancel each
other out but they are two separate
threads that each support the overall
topic of sharks there are two distinct
ideas here with equal importance this
passage teaches us that a sharks are
deadly so they are scary and b deadly
animals must be protected because they
are important neither of these ideas are
more or less important than one another
they are both main ideas
when you're considering whether or not
there are two or more main ideas ask
yourself are both x and y equally
important understandings from this
passage or is it just one idea
supporting another so with this in mind
you too can learn to travel in two
directions at once with the power of
your mind and the power of reading
you can learn anything
dave it out
how can you be into places at once when
you're not anywhere at all